bonjour youtube et petit peuple et d
internet je suis aujourd'hui avec le
grand l'unique le seul mais aussi de
multiples super flame cl le tout le
monde je vous présente cet ovni de
youtube dans ce magnifique tu imites le
mec qui parle pas moi je suis pas trop
dans la spontanéité je suis toujours
tout seul face qu'à ses saints ben je
peux partir vas-y par toi rentre chez
toi lorsque tu va nous laisser tuer le m
je prend le contrôle de cette vidéo
abonnez-vous à machin au revoir si tu
veux je te donne un temps d'imitation tu
peux dire ce que tu veux comme tu veux
et si tu veux d'accord voilà monsieur
bonjour c'est jean pierre pernaut
bienvenue dans ce trésor aujourd'hui on
se retrouve dans une vidéo de fabien
olicard un reportage nous nous trouvons
actuellement région parisienne dans les
locaux de fabien olicard mentalist très
connus comme nous le confirme josette sa
grand-mère à bâle à petit fabien depuis
qu'il est ok fait des trucs bizarres une
faille mamata léger porte je gagne deux
fois de l'argent de poche l'enfoiré
simpson a décidé de témoigner également
et bien fabien l'écart et c'est un mec
super sympa mais j'aimerais bien kim est
mentaliste pour kim apprennent à manger
encore plus de 2,9 que je peux en manger
actuellement est aussi skis pour
mentaliser pour que je puisse changer
les choses en bière bravo merci bravo
toile rappeler que du studio tu
applaudis
c'est beau c'est précis maintenant tu
vas nous apprendre à faire une ou deux
voies et moi je vais mettre à votre
place je vais essayer de le faire même
temps comme ça vous pourrez pas être
plus ridicule que moi oui le des liens
ou pas parce que en plus de ça je vais
être ridicule doublement parce que je me
sentir jugé
tu vas par le maestro et entend leur de
maestro c'est toi un personnage joué par
roger carel
ils ont d'ailleurs arrêté sa carrière
récemment mais qui est un homme
exceptionnel donc des hausses que je
peux proposer c'est tout simplement la
voie des des journalistes la voix off
des journalistes de rage parce que ça
c'est vachement plus de la prosodie
qu'une voient en m
ouais la prosodie c'est un peu la
mélodie de l'avoir c'est la manière de
parler tu veux essayer de reproduire
cette mélodie mais en parlant hockey
avant de faire ça on va déjà essayer de
la reproduire ensemble entendez la la la
la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la ça s'est lassé
spes de mélodies que tu peux venir
claqué sur du texte
genre une phrase j'adore les chats avec
l'intonation journalistique ça donne
j'adore les chats à fouetter
c'est hyper marié tatatata j'adore les
chats j'adore les chats j'adore les
chats essaie de tirer les syllabes sur
la fin j'adore les chats il faut
vraiment dramatiser ton discours même si
c'est un truc joyeux il faut que ce soit
dramatique
il semblerait que les personnes
regardant cette vidéo ait envie de la
laïque et si c'est bien le cas ils
seront invités à aller découvrir la
chaîne de super flame en cliquant dans
le lien sur la description c'est
vraiment pas mal mais entravé tirer un
peu plus imbécile avait dramatisé fera
ajouté plus de juin stress au niveau de
la mélodie vraiment opérateurs hba ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta il paraît que lorsque
l'on clique sur le lien dans la
description on est redirigé vers la
chaîne de super flame toi tu peux leur
faire un coup la nouvelle vient de
tomber
il paraît que lorsque l'on clique sur le
lien dans la description on atterrit sur
une vidéo de super flames j'étais pas
mal bon ben là c'est parti pour les
jumeaux ouais c'est effrayant ça c'est
parti pour deux jours la jument il vient
de proposer higueras et grichka
bogdanoff alors écoutons choisi qui a
déjà on voit le chef sur une voie en
posture qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celle de jean-pierre c'est ce que
j'allais dire d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs j'ai une loque leur voix en
imitant pernaut d'accord qu'est ce que
c'est un jeu vidéo dans cet état je ne
fais chier au jeu le flash et
deux voies qui attend de nous que
d'autres parce qu'en fait la voix des
bogdanoff c'est justine et puis moi que
je la voix de jean pierre pernaut mais
en vaches meurent plus punchy et un
légèrement plus les nus hockey jean
pierre pernaut est comme ça et gorillaz
kamolov ils sont un petit peu au dessus
je souhaite parler c'est pas mal qui ne
fait pas sa charge les sangles sont
comme s'il avait parlé de tennis à ce
niveau la belle tenue une balle de
tennis de voûte d'une balle une balle
rouge part j'ai fait mais je pense que
les bouffeurs 25 kg vous un vin non
réponse ils ont fêté jour en parlant
cette fois comme groupe i pour bonjour
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour pas mal
après ce qui est bien avec le team usa
leur mère c'est pas mal pas mal de ma
mère quand j'ai cinq ans je faisais un
gros que j'ai bouillie sur un des cinq
ans sont pas morts c'est qui ça c'est
assez toi bonjour gore bon je rigole
bonjour igor bonjour bonjour idar
bonjour record
bonjour les gars bon jour et jusqu'à
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ton x
la fin oui mais moi je vais faire mais
itv gare bonjour your d'aujourd'hui
jusqu'à bienvenue à cette nouvelle
émission émissions culinaires et
bienvenue dans ce pays cuisine la
cuisine de l'espace
on serre la gorge pour parler un peu
comme ça en gonfle appelé jours pour un
show un peu plus haut on relève
légèrement la langue et on rajoute
d'énergie comme si on criait on passe
donc de jean pierre pernaut à 1 igor et
grichka bogdanoff
voilà les i c'est assez simple sur pour
fabien je peux spontanément prendre des
voix et je sais que c'est un c'est assez
rare pour en avoir discuté avec d'autres
imitateur parce qu'il ya quelques années
j'étais invité au festival national de
limitation à carcassonne et j'avais
discuté avec d'autres imitateur il
m'avait dit mais toi c'est ouf
tu peut basculer d'ottawa normale à une
autre voie mais en une fraction de
seconde
alors que ils ont besoin de se préparer
à rentrer dans le personnage avait
commencé à faire des jeux c'est tout et
moi je veux ce père aimant changer ma
voix et c'est assez effrayant pour la
plupart des gens oui les tutus qu'on
pense
ce que je t'ai vu faire t'as pas besoin
de compenser avec toutes les sarkozy on
vous a vu passer quand j'ai déjà entendu
une voix où j'ai souvent été exposé à
une voix je peux la reconnaître
n'importe quand quand elle ressurgit
typiquement je me souviens il ya
quelques temps sur sur l'émission de
guillaume pley il en est les piéger andy
raconte d'ailleurs que iad kevin tran de
la chaîne de rire jaune qui avait appelé
en dira compte il a parlé pendant 10
secondes et je savais que c'était lui
qui est en train de parler d'accord j'ai
envoyé un petit message sur twitter est
en train de passer sur l'énergie mois
seulement voilà il va il n'a pas répondu
qu'ils étaient les phases en fait et
s'est avéré que c'était lui
mais genre en 10 secondes chrono je
savais c'est élise au téléphone parce
que j'ai reconnu sa manière de parler en
fait d'accord entre les braqueurs et
jeux pour je pense un concept que
j'essaie de développer c'est un peu le
concept d'empreinte vocale je pense que
tout le monde n y emprunte une empreinte
vocale un peu comme on a tous une
empreinte digitale et que cette
empreinte vocale est composé de diverses
éléments donc la prosodie la manière de
parler la voix en elle-même le
vocabulaire un truc comme ça
après j'ai eu qu'à une petite technique
quand je veux volontairement faire une
loi qui est de me dire plus je connais
tu vois plus je peux potentiellement en
faire d'autres
parce que je raisonne vraiment un peu
comme si c'était une espèce de toiles
d'araignées ou des mois que je te dis
oui je comprends et je raisonne en
termes de risque ses proches d'une
imitation de cette affaire par exemple
la voix de jean pierre pernaut comme on
l'a fait en l'introduction dans cette
vidéo était proche de la voir des frères
bogdanoff et du coup a dès l'instant où
j'ai été capable de maîtriser la voix de
jean pierre pernaut j'ai eu assez
rapidement le déclic de me dire mais
attend la voie des frères bogdanoff
c'est un peu le même genre de voix un
peu étouffé s'offrir un peu chiche jeu
comme quand tu prenais la référence de
la toile d'araignée sept joueurs
vraiment la visualisation de toit au
centre par exemple la paire de là et là
du coup d'oeil d'avoir un bouc
d'anastacia qui incrémente en un petit
détail emplois là c'est typiquement
kardex correctement ça c'est très très
clairs et par exemple la voix de roger
carel que vous entendez à l'heure
actuelle c'est le mec qui fait la voix
d'astérix donc là je suis en train
d'imiter sa voix quand il part
normalement et astérix et la même chose
mais en un peu plus nasillard 1 c'est ça
et je raisonne vraiment comme ça et un
point il ya vraiment un espèce de
travail de comédien en plus tout
simplement
l'imitateur un changement de voie et
ouais spontanément quand je prends une
voix ngos je suis un peu plus jamais
allé je vous mets tissés quartier c'est
trop cool la vie bien un truc comme ça
cool hyper intéressant merci pour tout
ça si ce temps plein merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo tchèque et
sa chaîne en descriptions un petit live
un petit abonnement à moi aussi si c'est
pas déjà fait abonnez vous à ces chaînes
il ya la mienne gros bisous ou moins
mesdames et messieurs nous observons
actuellement deux particules abonnement
qui viennent du cosmos elle vient
d'arriver sur votre ordinateur ou d'un
smartphone tous les pans du support que
vous utilisez appuyez dessus et vous
serez redirigé vers une aventure
absolument extraordinaire tout à fait
tort
[Musique]